[Music]
[Applause]
aute what a what a l what a l what an
[Music]
absolute ah what a lad well we've done
it we've finally got him on one of the
alltime great Lads and many would regard
him as the greatest Marco of all time
and any you speak to any of the
Highlanders from the 2015 team and
they'll tell you how influential he was
in their side winning the 2015 Super
Rugby title and he also is in my opinion
probably the best player to have never
been kept internationally while post
playing he also went on to become one of
the best offensive coaches in the game
and he has an incredible story which I'm
really looking forward to talking to um
one of the greatest men of all time it
is the great Shane Christie welcome mate
I love your
intros I love them thank you yeah I
spoke all true words there like some
good memories of you um playing for the
Marco and the Highlanders even New
Zealand moldies but um you've had a hell
of a career and um I not it's such a
cool story because I obviously um metet
you here at Nelson rby football club
great to be here at in the club rooms to
do this podcast but um your Journeys are
not your typical rugby Journey like you
you really ground through early days eh
y yeah lot of hard work at the
start and yeah it's like how did I end
up making it as a professional rby play
I was like w that happen yeah but it
took a long time I was late I was like
25 26 before I made Tas yeah we will get
all to into all that but how how you
feeling now like a lot of people
probably lot of the questions that came
in was where is he what's he been doing
um you were coaching the Highlanders you
were coaching Tasman now you're you're
not so what are you up to the last year
I've just taken a year off yeah um I
actually got cut from the Landers J did
you yeah I didn't tell you that no I
thought you left oh you got cut they cut
me oh really yeah it's a good story tell
it straight away yeah let's dive
straight
in it's uh just the way the season had
gone in the couple years that I was down
there I enjoyed it and the experience
was good but there was a lot more
frustrating days than than I enjoyed you
know I was a grind man for me my like
with trying to work through full-time
coaching with my concussion and stuff
and then the pressure
of trying to get into that level at
coaching yeah and then I guess the we
were a battler team that wasn't always
performing that
well
um so there was there was pressures in
in the whole experience but I couldn't
go back if it was going to be the same
if if if I was working really hard to
get the D right and then the attack was
wasn't the good and I didn't feel like
the
expectation on the standard and the
commitment and some of our Tech was was
probably in my opinion was letting us
down and of course I could be wrong and
things aren't always as you seen but it
was just like I felt like if I had an
involvement in the tech it could have
been the attacking breakdown or 22 and
Tech I think I could have help a better
influence and how we were scoring tries
in that and yeah yeah I felt like that I
felt like at times the there wasn't
enough expectation on how our attack was
going yeah and um the execution and the
standard that we set I just didn't
believe that it was the right M Way
Forward yeah so that was a cool
experience and like I think they're
going to get Kenny Kenny ly down there
next year which is awesome I've heard
he's a really good coach good good good
yeah but he good he said he's good he's
good it's got to be
good but you know I looked at the
Landers this year and they the same
problems M and man I'm happy I didn't go
back because I couldn't get through
another year like that yeah yeah if it
wasn't for surfing I would have been
struggling down there that's the good
thing about denan and the boys are
amazing man there's a lot of really cool
guys the coaches are awesome but I
think I just think the the expectation
sometimes isn't right down there and
when Jamie was there it was all on he
bought that you man yeah yeah people
like the like the stories that
even that you hear from the players that
have been under Jamie and burs when he
was on a another go or something like he
was for real
yeah head shots only yeah toughen up 500
a.m. he's the man and the boys respected
that and I think like a team
that for us anyway they don't have the
superstars down there so you have to you
have to be real if you want to win
against teams like you guys the
Crusaders the best players in the world
you got to bring an edge you got to be
different and it has to be your mindset
and expectation I think how else can you
do it right you can't you're right on
right how have they let you go that is
incredible but that was funny there a
funny story good start but you mentioned
like um struggling down there with your
head like coaching full-time while still
suffering from concussion like how is
your head now and like um what does
suffering through concussion look like
for you these days the last six months
have been tough since losing Bill man
yeah yeah um that was a that's been an
incredible experience for me and then
seeing how it happened
mhm um so without going into that just
right now that really rattled me and um
I suppose when with my concussion and
like I think a lot of people when you're
under serious stress you can get bad
headaches all your symptoms come back M
and then you just you've got a basic a
threshold of your energy and every time
you your battery drops if you get put
under stress it drops again and then it
just takes longer to get it back so when
I'd worked for I did a season my first
season in 21 with the Landers and then
went straight into tazzy m at the end of
those two seasons I was done yeah like I
was buggered my head had been I was
getting heaps of symptoms and I was just
grinding through still loved it and it
was good to get back to tasmine and
refresh and be under the sun and awesome
culture but going back into that 22
super season I was really
struggling and I guess that was an
experience that I probably wouldn't have
I wouldn't have signed 2 years for the
Landers even though I said I'm not I
don't know how this is going to go you
know I'm trying to get into full-time
work um and full-time coaching and then
the change of pressure and stuff it's a
bit more intense but um once I'd gotten
through that first year for those two
seasons I was probably operating at like
40 50% and then you get through the next
season so last July I got back to tazzy
and and I was I taken the tasma season
off to recover yeah I didn't start
feeling good till like January or
February all right Yeah man so what are
you feeling just headaches and tired
Hees fogginess
um like ringing in my ears vision
problems sometimes if I'm bad I'll have
issues with my speech and [__] yeah yeah
I mean you probably you may have seen
noticed different things in me and my
mood and the thing I remember as
coaching with you was like sometimes
just having to go off and have a sleep
you know like in the middle of like we
everyone would go for a coffee but you'd
go sit in the van and just sleep to rest
recharge recharge and I was like far
that's that's pretty crazy it is yeah
you just lose your energy faster you
know you've got you've got so much and
you can be like that and you feel and
operate maybe like a normal person but
then when you lose your energy you got
to get it back somehow and if you keep
on if you don't refill it it takes a lot
longer to come right M that's the other
thing so if I've got if I've got
headaches and stuff and I'm not feeling
that well um like you might feel like
that for a day or two and have a couple
good night sleeps it might take me a
week to come right yeah yeah and is
there light at the end of the tunnel or
like it's been how long's it been since
yeah 2016 I started having my concussion
yeah yeah um there's light man yeah I
know that I can come right because like
I said last this January February I was
feeling really good and I was exercising
hard out I got a chest freezer and I was
Ice bathing every day oh yeah like 15 20
minutes ice three or four times a day oh
wow I brought a
sauna I was doing hot colds every day
bro yeah yeah it's for real because I
like what's happened are you still doing
it yeah I started back up after um like
just recently like I I with the stress
of going through a billy and then I
helped with the girls team oh
yeah like when you're when you're busy
and you're trying to do normal stuff
your your health goes out the back door
you know so I didn't have the energy to
get back in the sauna bro to the ice
bath cuz it's hard you don't want to sit
in that ice bath for 10 minutes man
sucks but I know for for my life and and
to to come right I've got to do it and
there's other things that you can do but
I think the main thing there's is um is
ice bathing cold therapy high intensity
exercise when I can get my threshold up
I can actually run for 30 40 minutes but
just takes time to be able to do it yeah
and then fasting oh yeah so I've been
doing heaps of fasting the last year and
it's been a crazy year
but what does it look like for me in the
future I
suppose I want to try and I've been
speaking to New Zealand Rugby and losing
Bill and like man he had bad concussion
when he finished his rugby career and he
had other things going on
but seeing his behavior and you know the
way he was around different things in
his life I can see that he's still
having issues with his head
mhm and I just don't want to get to a
stage R where if you don't look after
this self that's where you end up and I
think it's it's really sad to see that
he couldn't get the right help because
like we're all responsible for our own
health that's for sure but when you end
up with concussion from rugby you might
think that like it is when you're
playing you get help for basically
everything but when you come off
contract and then on to ACC in the
public medical system you by yourself if
you don't have a a strong partner that
can handle your mood swings and your the
different things with the deal with
cognitive
issues or a family that understands it
really well you're by yourself and so
it's an interesting thing it be cool to
talk about that and we'll have a yarn
and see where we can come up with cuz
there's there's probably not enough in
New Zealand Rugby and prevention yeah um
and and then I think we for me anyway if
I hadn't had so many how many did you
have no idea heaps man I was thinking
about this before I came in my first
concussion was in
Tak when I was 18 19 playing for Nelson
Club s your
bees and I'd had a hi KN and I was
feeling a bit drowsy and the the bus
ride up to the top was like [__] this is
no good I'm feeling crook um the boys
were having a few beers bus trp home and
I tried to have a be I was like man I'm
crook as jumped out and
spewed vomited outside the bus and I was
like [__] this isn't good I've had a h
KN told the staff and I was like you
just
chill and that was my first concussion
when I was 19 and then my next one was I
think I was around 21 out here on tea
Park and there was a trial maybe
for the bay team and I tackled someone
and hit my head on their hip mhm and I
don't remember the time but Kaho stopped
me from walking the wrong direction
pulled me off the field and I remember I
came right into the ambulance and he was
like what's your name your address and I
couldn't remember for 10 or 15 minutes
[__] yeah and then that took me you know
a couple weeks off work
and um then couple weeks just gradually
getting back into it
and I
suppose that was before I even started
playing senior rugby and I like and then
went into provincial rugby for years and
then Super for a couple years but the
key thing that I absolutely think is
true is that I had too many in a short
period where I wasn't quite right and
like a lot of players we want to play so
you knew you weren't quite right I
didn't really understand that you may
may have concussion problems like I'd
had I was getting the concussion tests
and I was getting a little bit dizzy
during the week and um and I had a neck
problem from probably a head knock that
you know pinched my neck and and that's
how you can also get those referring
headaches and but yeah I realized I
wasn't right and then I thought right I
got through the Tasman
season and then I couldn't run high
intensity cuz he'd get a headache cuz I
just get like Blurry foggy
dizzy and then I thought sweet I'm just
going to get do weights did weights and
then went back into 27 uh 2017 super
season then contact was I was still
having problems and then running I was
still getting
issues with my high intensity running
for certain periods
so I just I tried to do we did a a
pretty good 3mon return to play protocol
with the doctor at the time Greg McLoud
and he really looked after me and he
tried to get me back and after two
setbacks of like high intensity running
for 30 or 40 minutes and I couldn't do
it then I knew it was probably time to
pop in but so yeah I had a lot of heat
dos like a lot boys do but the the key
thing is that a lot of my H knocks
weren't
actually like they might have been cuz
you with different doctors e and in
different teams and it's not always yeah
clear and it's not all the information
isn't connected or collected so it's
like I think that's the big thing that
we could do better in rugby
is soon as you start playing age grade
rug bear if you have a head knock that
needs to be noted down and it doesn't
matter who you're with if you continue
that that Sport and in a contact sport
you need to make sure that you've got
these concussions at different periods
doesn't matter what doctor you're with
or what team you would they need to be
noted in some sort of file system that
that you can have if you have five or 10
over a couple years you got to take a
year off yeah or
um yeah or even maybe a couple like T
Robinson is one that's had a few yeah in
the last couple years like I I see his
back and he's doing really well but if
he was to get a couple more next year
he's got to think about man this is
probably something I need to look at and
have a year off yeah yeah what would you
have done differently like if you could
go back in time would you have finished
your career earlier would you have taken
a bigger break earlier how would you
have done it the season the 2016 season
when I was getting them bad I'd come I'd
come into tasmine and I'd had a really
average 2016 Super and I was
disappointed with that and then it's a
collective thing with the player and the
the doctors yeah you know like it's
better now but only how long's that
7even 8 years ago it wasn't as good back
then and we were a little bit
more not lenient but we didn't
understand that man if you've had a
couple H knocks in one season this gu
red flag big time which now if you get a
couple H knocks in a couple Seasons
everyone knows that guy's sort of in a
you got to be weary and he gets another
couple he
out um even the return to play protocols
were only 5 or 7 days back then that's
been changed and really just recently
Now it's 12 days minimum for someone
under 21 or something so I think me
personally how would I have changed
things it's a maturity thing you've got
to say man I've had a h knock I'm not
feeling good yeah I've got to take a
couple weeks off and then the doctors
have got to take the lead and make sure
that that's and that's what it is now
but back then I don't know what I could
have done Jim it was I was a different
person you know I didn't see it like I
do now yeah I don't think many kids do
or many kids will that's why it's such a
hard area like you can fake those
concussion tests or pass those tests if
you want to and say that you're feeling
sweet and get back out there but um
you're right it's got to you've got to
take a little bit of accountability on
it h yeah you have to yeah I was I was
talking to fuzzy oh yeah last week and
we were talking about concussion test
and the culture back when we were
starting out it was
like the the first test you do you know
if you do it well but if you if you're a
little bit rough it probably means that
you're going to pass the next one if
you're not quite right so the culture
wasn't good amongst the players yeah and
that's changed a lot because we've seen
so many injuries with concussion and
people losing their careers and having
ongoing issues but yeah it took time to
maybe build that culture of concussion
safety up yeah and I've been surprised
it's taken so long because it's been
happening in NFL for
years yeah and I feel like even nl's a
little bit more behind it looks like
guys are out and then they
somehow push off the trainer or like go
for the HR and come back on and I'm like
well that's I don't know how he's
managed to do that but um did you see
that there was a um a doco on a dude
that lost his life up in Oakland a club
player in League no he had a head knock
and it was quite bad he was getting bad
symptoms for a few months I forget his
name I watched on
Sunday and he came back the doctors his
GP said you should probably take a month
off and he returned to play after a week
he took one week off returned to play
the next week got another head knock and
he died on the field all right and ACC
brought out some legislation that
automatic fre week stand down if you've
had a head knock M um and they did that
in a month and then League brought out
some rules some regulations saying the
similar thing and they did that within a
week yeah so how many more people need
to die before we do anything MH and I
think the awareness thing isn't is where
it should be there's no way I went to
after um I've been thinking about this a
lot since Bill
and there was a lady I forget I think
she's got a couple businesses around the
country her name's Helen she with the
Southland team and she's done some
concussion stuff with hunting oh yeah
and the old blacks she was had a little
um like a speech up here a bit of a
meeting and at the Pavilion I went to
that about 2 or 3 months ago and there
was 10 or 12 people there true y
so in a perfect world you'd have all the
club coaches there the age grade women's
and men's and educate the coaches so we
get a better culture around
concussion and there was a couple people
there mountain bikers a couple parents
that had kids that had concussion from
rugby yeah and then whose responsibility
is that to start organizing these
things well let's start with the
provincial unions and then ends at IU
probably need to take responsibility
about getting these um seminars into
rugby because we've got a problem with
concussion but there's not enough
awareness and is it because we're scared
of being honest about what's happening
with concussion
mhm like like in in rugby we're trying
and go towards the pressure Jim yeah
let's just confront it be open and
honest and then try and make sure we
have better awareness around it and
people are more educated so that it just
doesn't keep on happening because at the
worst
case it's the multiple head knock over a
short period that's going to mean you
have long issues later on but a couple
head knocks is you're fine you're sweet
you're going to be all good in a couple
months or a few weeks but not
consecutive H knocks and from a young
age if you don't keep track of
them yeah be patient with it eh but I
think that's why having you on this
podcast is so awesome being able to give
some awareness to the concussion world
and um share your thoughts and insights
to it all because you've been through it
all you've you've done it you've you
know that what it feels like and to be
able to share your thoughts and for
people to hear it young players might be
in the
situation make them realize that man I'm
not quite right maybe I won't play or
maybe I will take a month stand down
because I don't want to have these
multiple concussions in a row where I
could potentially die or um have
long-term injuries it's pretty scary
yeah and this is what your show's about
man it's cool it's cool what you're
doing J how cool it's uh it's
probably it's probably needed more often
and then than what we get in the
mainstream media and individual
journalism and podcasts is how you maybe
can get more real genuine yeah
communication going on that isn't you
know censored yeah that's it and about
concussion you know with with Billy's
passing
and his service out
here like there was a real fear around
talking about mental health and
concussion and what he went through
leading up to his suicide and there were
hundreds of people in The Pavilion as
friends that knew what he was like but
that was hardly addressed and then there
were probably a few hundred people maybe
a thousand people online I don't know
but I remember tuning in watching it and
where were you I was at the airport and
cross you about to catch a flight to one
of our games and remember you getting up
and speaking Yeah well that wasn't
genuine it wasn't for
Bill it
was anything
but the truth of what had happened to
Bill like he had done things in those
last few years
around trying to get his health right
man and a lot of people really tried to
help him and and his family tried to
help him and his mom spent 3 years with
him trying to keep him calm and get him
on the right direction
and but Bill was he found it quite hard
to change your lifestyle M and that's
it's tough I found it really hard to
change the way I was sort of just you
got to change how you are and when
you're feeling good you need to remember
that if you carry on like you were with
like sleeping or eating and overexerting
yourself you're probably going to have a
setback so it's a complete change of
lifestyle and for Bill that he found
that really hard and I think that
without the right support and stuff it
can it can it can lead to something
where you get bad mental health
and there was a real fear um to be
honest about what he experienced and
when I when I spent some time looking
into where he was for those couple
months after it's like
there was nothing there was nothing in
his life that couldn't have been fixed
with close friends and family but
because of the way he was probably
feeling he pushed a lot of people away
MH because he didn't want to be a burden
on anyone you know he was really
suffering mentally and it was it cuz too
many people myself included man as one
of his good friends at a time that I
couldn't understand that I needed to be
there for him just to listen I didn't I
couldn't I tried to be the help help
that I thought he needed but it's not
right you know we don't everyone's
different and um going back to the the
service it was like it's okay to be
honest about people having mental health
stuff and be honest about we had a rugby
coach that finished his career with
concussion and we're not even going to
address that and try and bring more
awareness for the younger players and
the current players because if we don't
be honest about what's happening man we
ain't going to go forward very
well what does that help like you you
spoke about um the type of help that he
needed like when you do see someone
struggling it I'm sure a lot of
listeners will know of someone who they
think far out he's struggling like what
is the best thing in your opinion to
help them Billy just needed someone to
listen to I think and then he couldn't
like he had a real problem with with
boundaries he was one of the most caring
loving people I
know over the last couple years he had
three homeless people living at his
house J true looking after them people
that he had met and he knew that they
needed a helping hand up and he took
them under their wing but he probably
wasn't capable of doing that because he
needed to help himself
mhm um so he needed real strong guidance
around him that understood his
condition and
maybe monitored them on a daily or
weekly basis where I
think you probably need a couple people
in your family a couple close friends
that really care about you a specialist
a GP someone in the union and create a
team around someone that's finished with
concussion MH and if that team
understands the player or the person
quite well and then say has a tough
couple months and pushes it couple of
them away and that relationship breaks
down then someone else needs to jump in
and the team around that person they can
help but they rely on each other so they
don't all take the burden you know yeah
and then have that going for and it
might take 3 or 4 years you know
but with with the medical system at ACC
is like you've got a case manager and
you'll have a specialist and maybe a GP
that can help you but they're not your
family or your friends and if you don't
have that partner yeah and if you don't
have that that family setup that can
actually support you and understand cuz
it's really isolating concussion MH it's
hard for people to understand what
you're going through and and it takes a
group of people to actually be around
them consistently and just check in
check in on what's Happening and
um Bill sort of pushed the people away
and then ended up being really isolated
and he was going through tough times and
I don't think anyone really understood
how bad he
was have you got that group around you
like you speak about people with
concussion needing that support have you
got that support that you need I do
Holly's been back in New Zealand oh true
since
last since this March or something and
cuz I was really bugged after bills I
ended up staying with her for a couple
months and she was I just good good
person to talk to she knows me well
and she's been helping me with I've I've
been getting a little bit of therapy and
um some
things to try and get my head right as
well and then I'm looking at some
different things that I can do for like
my diet and
um concussion like this that chamber
hyperbolic chamber and stuff like that
and there's a couple things that I'm
going to look into to try and get past
the stage I'm at but I've got a close
friend that I've been talking to Craig I
caught up with Craig the other day and
Craig Mo
um I've got I've got a group of people
that I can rely on and if I got to a
stage where I thought I was in danger
of going downhill or feeling like I was
suicidal then I'll give you a ring I
hope you do you know I've I've learned a
lot since since B bro and I think that's
one live message Bill in
August and and I was still trying to
help him like I thought he needed help
man it wasn't
right and he was he was reaching out for
help then but I didn't see it m but then
he wasn't able to say man I'm not right
I need help come and see me MH which it
takes it takes a lot I think yeah and
then when when you see a really close
friend take their life and then as it's
just like there's nothing that is a
problem people care about you and I
think you didn't realize that people all
over the country loved that dude he
played for so many teams and he inspired
so many players and people that were
older more experienced younger he was a
character
man and but he couldn't he couldn't
quite reach out and just say it how it
is because we're scared we're scared to
say the truth about a lot of things like
can cion how can we have a service for
someone that was an absolute legend in
the Marco Jersey and we couldn't speak
his friends couldn't
speak so we got to we got to get over
ourselves and this is what's happening
all around the world in in our country
not just about concussion but we're very
we're very scared of hurting feelings M
and we don't want to say the truth about
things anymore because we're worried
that it's going to cause more damage
then but it's not truth hurts but it's
temporary and how do you get progress
without it yeah it's something you've
always done even well ever since I've
know you've always been one of those
guys who have just told it how it is
like um no sugar coating stuff and I
think that's why you're such a great
coach cuz people knew um it was coming
from the right place and if it hurts
then it's probably it's probably true so
um and it's to make you get better so
something you've always done well I
think like your first question about oh
yeah how did I sort of get into rugby is
when I was when I was 21 my stepdad died
and then I realized like I was l in my
late teens and early 20s and then I
realized if I was going to try and make
rugby cuz when he died I thought man I
really want to give this a crack was he
a rugby player yeah he wanted me to be a
professional rugby wanted me to train
hard and I was just like pretending mhm
so then that's when I started really
talking to myself about man
stopped pretending and every time I
didn't want to go train I was say man
you got to do you got to work hard and
when I started being honest with myself
and then I had success I was like that's
probably the way to be MH so that wasn't
until what 21 21 he passed away and
that's what inspired me to start
training really hard yeah so what were
you like before that were you A Gifted
player coming through the ranks I don't
think I was gifted like talented as just
my game was built on effort yeah
tackling even from a young age yeah yeah
effort yeah and like later on I probably
got a bit more skillful getting coached
by good coaches and being around
professional environments and rangy and
KK and playing sevens really helped me
with my conf confidence that was a big
difference um my game was just effort
man yeah effort and honesty with myself
and then when I've ended up coaching I
try and even as a captain in different
teams just be honest about things and I
think that's the way forward instead of
no Sher coding
yeah so you you were born in Wellington
is that right I was born in py py that's
right yeah and then came down to Nelson
came down to Nelson School in Wellington
squint up at college for four five years
and in Wellington and played first 15
there had some really close friends that
I still kept in contact with there um
good experience playing rugby at first
15 but we were sort of I think second
then and yeah um and then came back down
to Nelson and played senior B's yeah
crazy yeah and you were building at this
stage like you were a builder for like
six years before yeah before he took
over started building at 18 and then
built till I was 25 yeah far out and
that was a cool part of the club was
like you most people were studying like
yourself or get into trade and then
Tuesday Thursday
training run around play touch and then
and do a bit of training and get ready
for your Club game in the weekend and
give it everything for the boys and work
really hard and then have a good weekend
few beers and real sociable at that time
in the club scenes and I think that's
something that I miss a lot we we were
real successful here yeah we built a
really good
culture um and then as the like tasmin
got made and you had something to Aspire
to be yeah get a professional but it
took a lot of work you
know
um and then don't know yeah I I remember
one pre-season in particular where you I
don't know you on the fra frame but you
weren't quite getting the cont the
Tasman contract or anything so you
thought about a position switch you were
going to become a second five this is
what you you planned I remember going
down to botanics and you're practicing
your your wipers into the corner
shanking them
everywhere I was like I'm not sure of
second five is going to be your spot but
um you're pretty keen on it so talk me
through that move and why you thought
that I think it was Bon that said maybe
changed to Midfield and there was Poppy
and Zane winslade and stuff at tesman at
the time and I wasn't getting I
wasn't I was getting making like the 34
man squad and then get cut when they cut
the team down to 30 and
I just wasn't good enough I wasn't
consistent enough and I wasn't really
big like my frame was small and I wasn't
naturally um that big and that didn't
help with my physicality and that but
yeah I know back Looking Back Now I
wasn't good enough I wasn't consistent
enough and then when I took it more
seriously and made more sacrifice in my
training and tried to understand the
game a bit better then I eventually made
it but it was a long process yeah yeah
it was was cuz a mission man and it was
intense I remember training with you a
lot of those sessions and we used to go
pretty hard like remember um going into
like the actual sides and thinking these
sessions aren't as hard as some of those
ones that we used to do like we did used
to train hard and um it was cool to see
that you go through those um ranks and
get to where you got to eventually but
um another move was when you went down
to the to BU played sevens or was it
sevens or F as
well it was sevens and I played 15s too
yeah so that was a big change in my
mindset yeah so I think I'd worked
really hard for three or four years and
got cut a couple years from that 30 man
squad for Tasman and then I was like all
right I'm not going to make it I just
got to suck it up had you given up on
the rugby dream in your mind in my mind
pretty
much and you're on the P Heap set yeah
like I was a lad yeah I loved it it was
cool man that's what I liked about the
culture you know you could work really
hard and then have fun party with your
mates
and recover Sunday and do it again yeah
and the year before I went down to
Bull I was like man I see all these
Semi-Pro people with the the Marcos and
the super teams that were training all
day MH and I was slogging working man
you know like8 9 hour days every day and
it's hard you wake up at 6 yeah go to
the gym till 7 then go do a 9h hour
shift and then training after yeah do
that for 3 or four years that's tough
and that's like like tan Robinson he's
done it with Craig Mo working with
Seymour Builders like that's been tough
yeah but it builds your character cuz
you know what hard work is and then I
did that for 3 years trying to make it
didn't make it and then I thought you
know what I'm going to quit work and
give it a really good crack yeah yeah
that's right so I I had a mortgage at
the time and I had a house and I was a
young dude I was like
24 um I thought I'm going to take a six
month like sabatical off building yeah
and give it a really good crack yeah so
I put everything in trained tried to
understand the game got my body right F
fast and then I got dropped again true
was like [__] D oh my head enough yeah
and then I
realized I went down to Bull at the time
of my life I was working with Craig down
there with his old man and Rosco
contractors and doing some building and
we're working 12-hour days
building and the people down in raon
work
hard so we're doing 12-hour shifts four
days a week sometimes 5 days a week and
then would go up to Westport play in the
weekend for bull yeah and then go back
down working another week and I did that
for eight months and then I played for
Buller down in Queenstown and the TW
Queenstown seven comp and that cuz i'
cuz I'd like let the dream of rugby go
yeah took the pressure off took the
pressure off bro let it go to get more
and then I realized that and which I
really understand now is Rugby's more
about the culture and the excitement of
what the game brings yeah it's not about
trying to be a professional and then
being an all black it's about like you
can never play as well as you can when
you're playing free and confident and
just loving the game yeah you're never
going to be good if you're not if you
don't have that mindset and then after
playing sevens for B it helped me with
confidence to run and tackle and be just
confident with the ball and I came up
play Club the next year and I was a
completely different player cuz I'd let
it go and then I was able to be play
free more carefree and with more
confidence
and yep and then I finally made it do
you think that six-month period where
you did train hard helped as well or um
was it a combination of both of them or
do you think it was mainly just the fact
that you let it go no I definitely would
have helped with my body like I'd built
a bit more muscle and yeah probably
understood the game a bit more and um
but mainly mental yeah more more so
mental you know like 6 months of
training you can lose that in a couple
months it was mental G like I completely
changed my mindset about what I thought
and I've yeah even at Super level like
for me playing Super Rugby I I needed to
be really on to be good and I need to
sacrifice and do the right things in my
preparation I didn't do that I wasn't
good enough to play consistently at a
good level but I think I still then I
needed to take the pressure off mentally
and then not worried about not worry too
much about performance and enjoy the
game more and the experience that I was
having instead of being like I'm trying
to play really good and yeah you said it
all the time in young players we put too
much pressure on ourselves and I think
that's maybe a lot to do with the
culture rugby in New Zealand yeah right
that's fascinating so then you do make
tasmine you don't play a huge amount
that first year behind couple of like
puffies and stuff of the world and then
was it the following year you start
getting a bit more of a crack then you
make New Zealand Sevens and you spoke
about that earlier but that being a a
bit of a game changer for you to give
you that confidence that you were I
guess good enough
yeah it was I never really got a real
good crack at New Zealand Sevens either
and again again that was another
stepping stone where I tried to develop
confidence at that level but never
really did M and then so I played a
couple seasons of M of 10 and I was
getting skittled like you think of Might
team now
it's
um you wouldn't think like it's it's a
good level but when I was playing I
still wasn't good enough to play that
level well yeah and then I thought [__]
I've got to go to another level M so
then one offse I think it was 20 I
played sevens 2011 didn't really get
much time for NZ and wasn't super
confident at that level but then in 2012
I came back got cut from sevens I think
and thought man I want to give try and
make super and I knew that I needed to
get my body bigger cuz I was like 91 kgs
oh true I was really light at the start
of my career and then I put on 12kgs
with a local Guy Brad Josie helped me at
results 12kgs that's a in an offseason
yeah we used to just do three-hour
sessions and I remember just spending
all my money on
fuffle for
gwn that's why the owner knows you so
well yeah I was having two a day and
thinking like I was eating cream rice
thinking it was good for me by the
when nutritionists told us cream rice
was like the dream
snack it's just
[Music]
sugar yeah and then the six months
during that um preseason for Club I put
on heaps of weight so straight after the
2011 M 10 cup season I was like man I'm
going hard yeah and I went hard for 6
months and I put on 12 kgs and then I
was way too heavy in club and I was
basically walking every but I knew I was
physical I just couldn't sustain it yeah
and then that following year leading
into the 2013 I had a pretty good season
on the balance yeah my body was bigger
and I was actually always determined and
I worked really hard so that sort of
filtered through maybe with my mindset
in the 2012 2013 season when we we did
pretty well in the second div and then
moved up and lost to use and yeah and
the final that I remember that game
against Hawks Bay that would be one that
probably stands out for you here at tea
Park and um close game go like Tasman
had always been you know the Battlers of
the comp really and then to see them win
that competition and in a game like that
with the crowd like riding to eh High
West on that last C like some special
memories for you that was a buzz man
yeah at the time I didn't realize like
yeah we knew it was massive and I I sh a
video on my Facebook the other day um it
was KK talking it was like sky sport
came down he was a legend man he looked
back at The Passion of the community on
watching the Marcos then there were
thousands of people out at tea Park yeah
um and that was probably a big reason
why e missed that kick but we were
Battlers like we were finishing second
to last third to
last right through till
2011 and then rang in KK sort of took
the team and we had a vision and we were
playing a real expansive attacking brand
and our philosophy was like move the
ball MH get exciting get excited about
our attacking brand and Inspire the the
town you know yeah School tries back
yourself and we managed to we managed to
do that and then grow our defense and
our discipline and set pieace and yeah
we had a couple good years but we had a
lot of support from the community and it
was like cuz we were coming up
together as the the club scene with the
people that from the Marcos were playing
Club m and then we got successful in
Tasman yeah and then those players we
ended up getting heaps of super players
and now all blacks
and it's like there's something that's
missing there for um the connection
between our Province and the club to
keep that excitement in the community
going it's it's
definitely sort of yeah I think it can
be brought back and was it post that
season you get signed to the Crusaders I
don't remember you being a Crusader but
yeah for eight
minutes is that all you got yeah yeah so
were you a full Squad member yeah yeah
yeah true I think there was a season
where Richie had a year off and was
taking a sabatical and I jumped in and
Matt Todd was like the number one yeah
it was after the 2013 season when we did
win that Hawks Bay Championship oh yeah
yeah
um yeah I wasn't fit enough was wasn't
fit enough I went down there preseason I
realiz wow I'm not fit enough is this
cuz you were too worried about putting
size on I just wasn't you know you go
from tasmine to your first super
campaign and it's with the Crusaders
bro they were fit and they were elak and
the training intensity was like it
probably even more so now but for me I
was just hanging around at Club level
and yeah um just didn't have the the
base for endurance and didn't understood
didn't understand what it took like to
back it up dayto day I didn't have that
either like the day-to-day training I
didn't have that in my body and I really
struggled
but Matt Todd played awesome he was a
really good player and I got an
opportunity against the force like round
seven or eight and then 8 minutes in man
popped my rib and I was done was oh did
you start that game yeah oh that's n it
was a buy yeah was it was a shame cuz
I'd worked really hard to try and get an
opportunity then I got injured straight
away m and then that was it didn't get
another crack but then and that's T like
cuz because you were an older athlete
how old were you at the time like 26 27
26 yeah and to get that crack and then
have it taken away how hard was that
sort of injury at that bad time to deal
with frustrating yeah yeah it was a big
step like I when you have these I think
the development stages in your career
and your in the time it's it's way
different than what you see now but was
it hard it was frustrating cuz if i' if
I'd been prepared and gotten fitted
before I went down there I could have
handled it more yeah and kept up better
m i remember the first one of the first
days of Fitness testing like we did a
Bronco and I I did pretty good and I
think I beat mat to by
one I thought yeah sweet I'm all good
and then 15 minutes later we did this
running
thing I just got everything head into
that into I think it was the beat test
right yeah and then I came with
something like dead last and this 3K run
or something I was like this is tough I
couldn't sustain the conditioning yeah
well I could imagine you doing that L
going so hard in that one event just
like they didn't tell me this I'm
competing here cuz you're you're a
competitor he like um want obviously
there probably competing against mat
Todd doing anything you can to beat him
he's probably knowing that he's got
another 4our session coming up and he's
been in it for like the environment
that's why I think uh the development
stages into professional rugby really
helps but if you don't go through that
like I did it's like you learn a lot
fast and it can probably be a little bit
like yeah costly if you don't understand
what you need to put in yeah so what
stopped you being a crusader the
following year was it just Richie was
back oh yeah so they got rid of you and
Jamie Joe calls you yeah yeah basically
yeah how did he sign you I know he's
quite good at signing
priz what happened there no he was all
good I played in the 2012 mold team oh
yeah under him under him yeah and I'd
played pretty well
and uh I was already signed for the
satus the following year and then we
played
the Highlanders in 2013 in Christ Church
and he came up to me in the changing she
he's the man
bro the Crusader has just smash the
Highlanders and he rolls and sits down
boy what have to next year oh yeah yeah
and I was like oh nothing I'm not signed
here I be Ken's come down he like yeah
come down and then so I think I signed
there for a couple years and um I went
away with the M's team again on 2013 and
this is a funny story about
Jake I did my knee like the last play of
a game I think we were playing USA or
something my did a bit of damage and I
was going to be out for 3 or 4 months
and he Rings me up he goes how's the
trip this was after the M tournament it
was before preseason of the ATL is 2014
yeah I was like no it's good it was good
I enjoyed it and you know good
experience traveling and I've got this
bad knee and I'm probably going to be
out for three three months and he loses
it yeah you
yeah what are you talking about man
don't your doctors know you know yeah
this isn't my fault and that's where the
communic between even the Mal's doctors
and the Highlanders doctors there was
none true it's crazy so I'm out for I've
got I've got a contracted player that's
out for 3 months with bugged
knee and the coach doesn't even know so
these things in our rugby games only
just starting to develop like the
confidentiality causes with players
medical stuff that's good but not with
rby players when they've got damaged
knees or concussion yeah it needs to and
I think it's better now it's like clear
transparency across the board so
everyone knows where a players at back
then like Jake was nutting out
saying nothing at you there's nothing at
me like it's my fault I'm like bro hang
on playing for my country what what what
was that like um playing for the moldies
cuz it was cool and you were obviously
playing for them before You' played
Super yeah so did you feel like
comfortable in that environment or did
you feel intimidated no it was really
good the 2012 season was just like there
was mainly like I think there was a few
Super Players but mainly provincial
players oh was it oh true um that's
where I met a lot of the boys from the
Landers Jared ho really looked after me
he was a good fell to me I was like a
new sort of dude
and
um you know I didn't feel the pressure
there it was different it was like the
multi teams that that's a really nice
thing about the multi team it's more of
a it's real family orientated and it's
just the you try and build the culture
before the professionalism of the game
and that's really important I think for
all teams to understand doesn't have to
be about multi but the teams are
actually about family and culture yeah
instead of before you go and try and win
a World Cup or provincial super and you
just do it you do it at the Crusaders
really well you can see it it's obvious
as but a lot of teams don't do that it's
about um player in playing good yeah
he's in there's no good he's out yeah
and that's where players we we sense
that eh yeah players sense that and they
won't give it everything if everyone's
not all in and you don't have that
culture or the family sort of
environment you don't get the best out
of everyone and the MTI teams the first
couple years I wasn't it Jake really
brought that that's that's I think one
of his biggest assets is he's he's
really empathetic for the players
whether you're playing well or you're
not mhm cares about the person more so
about the rugby player and and um he's
honest yeah and players can handle the
honesty I think that's what we forget
players are honest to each other and
that's how you get the best out of each
other but as the higher you get up I
think the honesty goes out the door a
little
bit I think I'll tell you a story about
the Landers this is a good one when I
went down there and when I was coaching
6 weeks into the campaign of 2021
Highlanders season I find out brny is
leaving overseas halfway through the
campaign yeah I remember that I lost the
gym I was so gutted yeah um and I think
that's
where if if Roger and whoever organized
that had been really clear with me and
the other coaches the management the
players didn't know at the
start then there wouldn't have been a
problem but it was a problem for me
because I've never in a team and I've
never wanted to be a part of a culture
that isn't together we're on the same
direction going the same way everyone's
and that's how you can build something
special halfway through the season and
then your head coach just leaves
bro I was gutted and I was
bitter everyone makes sacrifices to do
things and yeah and you just know need
to be clear and transparent from the
start and if you've got things like that
that are going on in professional teams
they need to be open and honest with
players coaches
everyone otherwise you're going to end
up having a disjointed team and I love
the Highlanders but that's what it's
been like for the last couple years so
I'm so stoked to see Jamie go back there
and hopefully revive them and I'm sure
he will yeah well he obviously did
during your time there because obviously
I remember that 2015 final pretty well
um on paper I don't know if you guys
felt the same but that Hurricane's side
was way better than was way better than
your side but um that's culture man 100%
culture and what you're talking about
that whole thing that everyone's playing
for that same purpose and you could see
it you could feel it out there yeah guys
are smoking me like if felt like every
time I'd carry I'd get absolutely smoked
like so hard I was like far out these
guys are these guys are wrong yeah it
was Unreal I wasn't only I had a
hamstring season that year and I only
played the semi in the final but the
boys that really really carried the team
for the good group core the core group
of players
that were in the team consistently
through that season man they they had an
awesome season and it was cool to see
and watch during the year and then be a
small part of it at the end was Unreal
and they had the ups and downs like I
remember I think it was waras they got a
hide in 551 or something three or four
games before the semis so it wasn't all
just I remember the Hurricanes pumped
yet did you um must have been like a
couple of games before as well up in
um Hawks Bay or Napier and it was like I
think you guys rested a couple but I
remember that game cuz I was like oh St
we're sort of playing these guys again
in the final cuz we're just beating you
by about 50 points and um going into
that final thinking oh
sweet no we had it like we had good
coaches Jamie
brownie um Scott
storm um they were super Innovative for
that time like the way we're playing Bry
used to always talk about kicking STS
and ball and play time yeah um stormy
was awesome
with defensive like tactical kicking and
pressure plays and
um Jamie was awesome around the set
piece and being Innovative at defense
and attack with the Ming and different
specials and and then their attitude was
right and it was sort of just come
together in the last couple
weeks um and I guess like any team you
have to go through those hard weeks and
learn to get better and come out the
other side and we had good players too
man they just hadn't been like they
weren't showing yeah hadn't had their
opportunity or yeah all coming with a
little chip on their shoulder I me like
why sucking the holos of the world like
had a terrible time up at the blues got
those opportunity down there and Mal was
the man yeah yeah our backs were Elite
Bucky yeah the back truck he was the man
but our forward pack was really
underdogs like that were basically might
10 Cup players yeah and then to go
physically against some of the better
teams it was cool um and that was all
ude that's where Jake really got the
best out of a lot of the players in that
team yeah and obviously the probably the
number one question Reon it was like 90%
of the questions that came in for you
were post that 2015 final like the
celebrations obviously there was
pictures of you and your kit for I don't
know how long you're and your kit for
but a decent amount of time and talk to
me about those
celebrations uh 4 days I was in my it
yeah I don't know what come over this is
so good I'm not taking off my jersey
there's no
way I can't believe it you think about I
think about back now I as was like a
club player for 7 years yeah grinded out
doing a trade and playing Club yeah and
then couple years later I'm in a
superfinal I'm not taking my
Jersey no
way and that was so cool to experience
that what a buzz and I was just a small
part of it um and to be around the
players that you're with and to do what
we did against a team like you guys had
you were awesome players and had been
for a long time some of the legends of
our game in our
country
um and the D was
like all night in Wellington still
running around my boots the next morning
yeah I think I got told by the manager
to put some shoes
on were you supposed were you supposed
to fly out with the moldies that night
oh yeah yeah this is another thing
about culture we can hopefully you got
some time I want to talk about some
let's go man so like that was a real
interesting experience for me because I
had been so um because I think my
character and I really want to I want I
want to experience winning a Super Rugby
final and spend time with your family
and the friends that you did it with
well I think the next day the mul team
was supposed to go overseas yeah and
when I'd sort of heard that we can't
even a couple days to experience that
with the team and there was six or seven
of us and we were like man this is nuts
you know you just put yourself through
this
8mon pretty intense campaign have an
amazing experience and enjoy it and then
the professionalism of rugby says go
away 24 hours later to the next campaign
it's like that's so far away from a
positive culture M um and I I just
couldn't I couldn't believe leave it and
I tried to speak to a few of the boys
and I say maybe we can organize with the
mold's coaches just to go 2 or 3 days
later it was like no there was no reason
for us to go they had like a game 8 10
days later and you know just roll in
couple days
late that's where I think commercialism
is taken over our game and it it's it's
been detrimental to the game and to the
players cuz you can see it and the
performances and and the campaign and
campaigns at Super level the All Blacks
and even our spectatorship you know if a
if a community and and the rugby culture
isn't thriving both Spectators and
players because of the pressure maybe
being too much it's because of things
like that like the expectation
to move on so fast from something you've
just given your life to yeah that's
that's it's irresponsible I honestly
think it is because you get the best out
of like that story I said when you drop
the pressure and Joy what what the game
is then you can get the best out of it
so you're in that celebration I think it
was in Kurt Baker's episode he was
supposed to fly it as well and he
remembers you sort of holding a meeting
with those guys and saying come on guys
let's let's stay you obviously stayed
you didn't go on that flight I I had a
igly hamstring and I was going to
be um like my hamstring was bugged and I
was I could have gone and then tried to
grind it out but it was I could have
been at risk of buggering it even
further yeah so my doctor said might not
be a good idea if you go straight into a
campaign you've just drunk for 3 days or
you know two days and then you're going
to go to a m east game you might cause
more
damage um so yeah I spoke to the boys
and I said hey like there's six of
us let's just say like let's connect
with the manager and the M's team and
we'll try and see if we can go back a
couple days late they said no and then I
like well my hamstring it's not 100
anyway I can probably say that I'm going
to stay with the boys and that's the way
it is but an interesting thing with that
I had a phone call from someone at New
Zealand Rugby and they said hey what's
up you're not coming to the m tourament
I said yeah my hamstring's not that good
and I said hey we should be going a
couple days later and they said
well this is the campaign schedule as a
player contracted player for New Zealand
Rugby you have to meet these schedule
requirements
and we could send you to some sort of
disciplinary board about not going and
that was my introduction to the
professionalism of our country's game
and I've and I've always seen it and now
I see it more because you look at the
community game and the provincial game
it's not going well and it's because
we've been overrun by these high
expectations to go week to week month to
month and it's like I said it's
detrimental to to the player and the the
communities around with supporters and
stuff so I didn't end up
going away on that Mish trip and I had
you know the best five days of my life
I'll never ever forget that and to sit
back and experience it like I think we
had a 5H hour lock in in the morning to
T it was out of
control I remember crying for about an
hour did you because of what just
happiness so happy man couldn't believe
you're getting calls from NZ oh no that
wasn't that was that was just like a
thing that I'll never forget and it's
made me a bit more aware of what happens
in in a professional sport and I
understand man we've got to be
professional and get the best out of the
players but I think it's gone too
far and that was a good example for for
me to see it firsthand that what
disciplinary board what yeah that's not
a
thing it's not a thing j
and of course you want to do the best by
each team you're in yeah but they just
absolutely they like degraded what
you've just been through and first ever
the Highlanders are still celebrating
that one for 8 years on you know you're
going to got to go two days later yeah
and the boys that didn't experience that
D you know they were more so part of
that team than I was and they had to go
to a campaign and no one remembers those
mold EXs you know at that time for those
players of course it's an amazing
privilege to be a part of a M's team but
what's 3 days for a player what 3 or 4
days you know it's not right with that
with that situation I just I hate to see
it happening in our rugby culture yeah
good on you got to have something you
got to stand on something you got to
have good
solid um morals and for me that's the
most important thing to me I'm not
always right man I'm wrong about do you
reckon it cost you playing for the All
Blacks I I no no I just wasn't good
enough you reckon yeah no way because I
I I reckon that following year I don't
know if it was the following year but
you were next level like you were
pushing it I think I I think the 2014
year I went to a camp for the All Blacks
I think tody was out and Rich Richie
might have been injured and
like I looked back at that time and I
was still all effort yeah I didn't even
know the game J I really only learned
the game when I started coaching oh
really yeah at detail
and with detail and it would have been
awesome to be in orake I always dreamed
of being in orake how cool but um I
think you could if you lucky enough to
get an opportunity through injury that's
May that may have happened for me but I
just wasn't and then I wasn't consistent
enough like at Super I I worked hard but
I wasn't always playing consistent and
like I said I need to be at my best
every week to play well and if I wasn't
at my best I just didn't always play the
best so was like so then how did it all
end for you like we've spoken about your
concussions and what was the final blow
and um when did you know that was it my
last game was 2016 for the moldies oh
yeah and I'd had multiple head knocks
and every clean out every tackle I was
getting ringers like oh yeah yeah little
little knocks and I was thinking man
this isn't good and then I I think in
that game I you know you know you do
like a couple tackles against a pad
before the game yeah I can't remember
who was the who was holding the pad but
I hit his elbow and it was just like
both pressure in my head and I'd had
these issues
M then I played 30 40 minutes into the
game and I was like man I'm not right
and I just walked myself off yeah and
then I was I remember sitting in the in
the changing room and the doctor came up
to me and I was even then I was like man
my neck's not right and he tried to do
the hia test and I was like don't worry
about it it's my neck MH and then I
couldn't really see that I'd had had
concussion problems for
months and then that was it and I tried
really hard to come back like 3 or 4
months I went hard did all the return to
play protocols just gradually didn't
overdo it but when I got to 80 90% I was
getting sharp pains in my head like the
running intensity was what was getting
me I could do weights reasonably well
but when I was doing High running
intensity stuff it was it was no good
and then
um and then 6 months after trying to
return a player finished and you know
even with the way that I finished with
concussion I remember reading a an
article in the media up in here and I
was with the Tasman team in 2017 and it
was like the mysterious case of Shane
Christian and it was
like that's really frustrating man yeah
a few questions came in about it like
what had what was this mysterious
illness and stuff and I was like it's
crazy that it was portrayed like that
yeah it's really crazy and I think there
was a few people that had been finishing
around that
time and to me at that stage I really
thought that they didn't want it to be
in the mainstream so Weir well it's it's
disheartening for a player that's just
you know given everything to a sport and
then had concussion problems and
consecutive head knocks and then the
media comes out saying
that what saying some sort of mysterious
cases like hey let's just be honest
about what's happened like people get H
knocks and if it's not really carefully
looked after you have to finish yeah
even the a disappointing thing was I'd
done these return to play protocols
carefully and gradually and I kept on
failing after 3 months and then in my
mind I'd known that I'd had multiple H
knocks and I wanted to
retire and I didn't see a specialist for
concussion for 9 months from the start
of my issues at the
Landers nine months nine months later is
when I seen a specialist and I had to
ring New Zealand Players Association Rob
nickel I had to ring him and say hey man
I need to get an appointment with the
specialist because you know GPS and
they're not
Specialists um that's crazy so the idea
to delay the inevitable for me was
incredibly frustrating it was hard and I
thought man what's going on this is
what's happening I've been open and
honest with my doctors about everything
this is what it looks like this is the
like I had records of having concussion
problems in tasmine you know
mhm
and that's where I think that we're just
not quite we don't we don't have it
quite right around our medical system
and the honesty transparency around
concussion and New Zealand Rugby and I
think if we get things right with the
transparency categorizing and making
sure that we have each and every
concussion filed for each player through
the grades and then
um make more awareness around concussion
so in Spain fzy was telling me that they
make all the age grade players where
hiar
M and we know hiar doesn't do
[Laughter]
nothing that cracks me up people like
we're head gear to help your concussion
or someone who's struggling with
concussion then we head gear the next
week think that still happens it does
still happen yeah yeah I was going to
say play that yeah but I mean you know
it might help with confidence and it
helps with scratches or
[Music]
whatever but it's not going to stop a
you know hit against a forearm or a knee
yeah and when you did finish when you
made that final call that yeah you're
not going to play again how hard was
that what did you miss miss the game did
you know what you were going to do
because it was taken away from you so
quickly back to building no I was bugged
man yeah yeah I was bugged I didn't I
was was I was worried about getting day
to day really yeah I was bad I was super
bad and like I said that 6mon period
where I couldn't get clarity around my
like I needed to speak to someone and
get some confidence around what does
concussion look like how long am I going
to be bugged for where am I with my
symptoms how come I can't run past 80%
those sorts of questions weren't really
answered and that's
stressful so for you know a year I was
pretty stressed out and uncertain I come
up to Tasman in 2017 and I hung around
with the team like I was pretty
crazy I still thought I was a
player I could probably tell you some
stories about
that I remember we had some new new
coaches Leo Crowley he would have a
laugh about this I think yeah he was
doing a good he's a good man he's done
really well with Wellington last year
and he was doing the D
and I was frustrated as cuz we weren't
that good and we were struggling away we
actually ended up making a semi I think
that year oh no we made the final but we
got spanked by can and we had a young
team oh yeah you know really young and
we did really well but I was nutting out
and I'd go to the office and say this is
what I think's happening and you're not
doing this you're not doing that we're
having big arguments and the other thing
around me then is like when you got
issues with ation and your concussion
problems you can be quite you know
abrupt yeah yeah and uh I was definitely
there is this how you got into coaching
cuz like you said you weren't really you
weren't really thinking of the game
technically technically as a player so
is it when this transition happened
you're up in the office telling everyone
what to do everyone's just like mate may
as well sign you CU you you're saying
all the right stuff no I think R looked
after me you know oh yeah yeah he' had
concussion and he looked after me and he
was really good and um but I I remember
texting
R like I pretended I knew what I was
talking about in that year when I was
still a player and yeah I said to ring
at the end of the season man can I get a
job coaching I want to do the D next
year and then it was just text and he
said yeah I'll talk to the other coaches
in the board and see what happens and
then I was like no no I need to know
now
and he said what you want me to tell you
over text right now I was like basically
just thought I was
crazy but you got it but I was
crazy and I did get it but that's what
I'm like I guess and it's it's probably
been um it's a good and a bad thing but
I was lucky at that time that rang
really looked after me because even that
following year in 2018 I was still
pretty bugged you know I I I'd try and
I'd try and understand the game at a
different level so I could help coach
with the boys and then deal with my
concussion symptoms like anxiety getting
up in front of a squad of 30 when you
don't even know what you're talking
about bro yeah it's hard and I used to
do some funny things like bringing x's
and try and try give the boys like you
know big packs of chops and stuff best
tackler and come up with different
things and it was fun but I I really
respect for how rangy helped me and
showed me a lot about D and the game and
coaching and understood that I probably
wasn't that good with my head and they
just like gradually help me and goody
was there at that time and he was a big
hand with helping me with different
things so I was I was lucky to get in
coaching through Tasman yeah I don't
think a lot of places may have said they
wouldn't have given me the chance even
Tony Lewis when he was here he put up
with me for a few years like I went from
playing to coaching after a concussion I
was still thinking you I was a player
for a couple years yeah what do you
think you would have done if they didn't
pick you up I just would have went
somewhere else UND decided that I wanted
to coach yeah like I was talking to once
you get something in your mind that
you're you're going to do it I was
talking to Ash and I was good mates with
Ash at that time and I was still good
mates with them but um I was like bro
who's your D coach next year for the
bay like a might as well come up there
you know I just wanted to coach I like
the environment I love the culture and I
thought could help and if I could learn
and get an opportunity somewhere then I
might be able to do it so what didn't
you love about coaching um not getting
my own way M yeah cuz I'm stubborn I
think that I'd want to do things the way
I want to do it and I think that I'm
right until I get proven
wrong that's a funny way to be Jim yeah
because you need someone that you're
challenging to be really clear yeah and
calm so they can tell you quickly and
you oh yeah know I'm wrong it's all good
but if they're not clear and calm and
then they get angry likeu we to have an
argument damn
it far out I always remember you being
really calm and clear as a coach like
when people would challenge you you'd
always be real calm
honest and it never really looked like
you got too rattled it's not definitely
quite often it wasn't how I was feeling
was that and I used to have to think
about it a lot like I'd try
and
like I got B anxiety bro yeah I didn't
never notice that either like you always
looked so confident and you've always
been one of those guys who can say
whatever it always felt like You' just
say whatever and you'd go into a shop
and tell them what's the cheapest price
they could give you like not many people
go and do that like um you just always
looked like you had no sort of fear or
anything with that but to hear that you
had anxiety in those meetings and stuff
was was interesting yeah it was crazy
um I never had anxiety until I had my
concussion oh yeah and then when that
happened and then it would come and go
depending on how our head was like if I
hadn't been sleeping well or um if I'd
been on the computer too much that
really got me you know and then I'd
start getting anxious and then what I
did know is that it was just
temporary and then if I could just get
myself through it it would pass but I
had to second rice myself for the boys
basically you know like if I wasn't
honest with myself and just like it's
all good man this is just invisible it's
your mind and people here care for me
and I had actually I trusted a lot of
the the coaches and the players they
really looked after me like the the
senior boys that I played with Dreer and
Davey and like all those boys I knew
that they had my back and I knew I
wasn't
perfect but they knew I meant well and I
cared and I wanted them to be good and I
wanted us to be successful and I think
that's what gave me the confidence to
get through that without without
stressing out about it too much so you
just got to for me anyway I just put
myself out there and I know I'm not
perfect no one is
But anxiety is an interesting thing like
cuz I know it comes and goes I know it's
just
temporary and ice bath ice B thing is
really good for it is that the best
thing for it yeah w 100% yeah is that
instant or is that something that has a
longer effect you got to do it after
multiple days but it does something to
like suppress your nervous system so if
your nervous system's really wound up
like I was at the
Landers then you're you're operating on
a different energy man it's like it's
real it's real like a garly wired up
sort of energy and you can function on
it fine for months and you don't have to
sleep that much and you're you're
basically fine but when you calm down
and you get back to normal normal life
it's like whoo I'm beat up yeah we
normally just sleep eat healthy rest and
recover and you're normally happy and
stuff yeah when you're operating on a
weird nervous system it's just like
you're wired all the time I do love a
good ice bath but what were you doing 15
minutes yeah like July last year I was
like straight away I knew I sat ahe I
had to do ice B thing and I was just
doing two or three minute cold showers
morning and night and when that was easy
I got an ice chest
freezer and then I started out just a
couple minutes three or four times a day
and then cuz I wanted to be healthy and
I need to get my energy way up so then I
don't come back down quick and then just
started 10 minutes 3 times a day 15
minutes three times a day yep so more
and more and then
uh like I'll get back and I'll get my
I'll tell you a story about um
a two we period and it wasn't that long
though where i' i' been real stressed
and my concussion was having issues and
I was having real foggy and headaches
often and um I started getting real
paranoid MH and I think this is
something that Billy may have
experienced as well man
because in these moments of paranoia
it's not really you and I I I didn't see
it at the time but I was having these
paranoid moments thinking I'd misplace
someone something and someone had stolen
something from me and someone had come
into my house and red me and I just cuz
I wasn't thinking clear enough I
couldn't see the reality
M and then when you go through these
sort of manic stages and when you come
out of them you got pressure in your
head cuz you just put your body through
this
pressure well if that that happened to
me three or four times over a two we
period and then it just wipes me out for
3 or 4 days and then I'm bang back to
square one with my head and I've got to
be in bed and got to do all the right
things to recover in there and it's
because like
stress um too much
workload uh having issues with your
cognitive problems and then keep on
pushing yourself then you do you
definitely start losing your ability to
think clearly and then the putting
paranoia on top of that it can be really
really hard and it's not easy to come
out of these things and I think
experiencing that recently was that the
first time you'd experienced it paranoia
no no no had that had it earlier in my
um like couple years after the
concussion but during the worst stages
so
20 2018 I started my first year with
coaching for tesy M and then I do the
tesy season it's been the next sort of
six months
recovering and I was helping with the so
I was contracted for Tasman for the 3
months and the season and then I would
do a little bit of community stuff in
the offseason but that offseason I was
bugged yeah you know I was like tired
and it would take months to come right
for the Tasman season right so that was
years and during that time I had
paranoid moments where i' I'd misplace
something or I'd misinterpret a friend
and have a crack at them and then push
them away cuz I think man you're playing
up but it's really cuz I couldn't really
see things that clearly
MH and then
I'll tell you a story about when I was
bad after the 2019
season we won and it was Unreal season I
think it was our
first um Premiership Victory who was it
against a Wellington out here oh yeah
yeah yeah I went out had a couple beers
with the boys the next day I was wiped
out and you wouldn't usually drink a no
I wasn't drinking but like staying up
all night that's tough for me and then
like a couple beers like literally a few
be and that's it and then the next day I
was buggered bro like felt like I was on
a boat spewed during the day and I was
like man I've got to right The Season's
gone we're up really high and
functioning on that like super anxious
type of energy that was hard to
understand but my nervous system would
been buggered and then when you come
down and then you're by yourself trying
to recover and then that's when I
started having issues with paranoia and
stuff mhm and then going through the
recovery stage with my head but it's not
really that
clear and
then I was doing all the right things
cold therapy this was only a couple
weeks after the 2019 season every day
and I was seen a psychologist about just
hanging on keeping it together and then
for a couple months every day I was
walking in Isel
Park
and my head was so bad man that I'd walk
past trees and I'd see myself hanging
from
it what an IM like a visual image visual
image and then I knew that my head
wasn't right Fu right yeah and that
happened for you know a good month and
I'd spoken to a psychologist about it
and that's how bad my concussion was and
that's I was I was coaching
fulltime but the the the fatigue that
the season had on me and I'm and the
fatigue that the season had on
me that's like when you when you lose
the energy and you lose your battery and
then you're operating down here yeah it
takes a long time to get back but as
you're trying to come back you're trying
to get your head right and on the way up
your head's not functioning that clearly
you know and then you're thinking things
and you're doing things and saying
things that aren't yourself and I
understood that then that I wasn't in a
good place m
and I'd looked
into things like hallucinogenic drugs
overseas MDMA you know the stuff that
was on the news the other door day on
The ranly Shield yeah well they use that
for um like therapy in the states for
different mental conditions and they can
use it for concussion conditions to
reate your neurological Pathways there's
MDMA therapy cocy therapy I waska Iber
gain these things that actually help
your your mind to maybe see a different
perspective or change the wires in your
mind have you done those I did when I
went after that really really bad stage
after the
2019 campaign I knew I was bad bro and I
was like man I've got to go um and try
and get into something like this because
the care that I was getting from like
ACC and in New Zealand we don't have
that New Zealand it's just
anti-depressants and if you're having
problem sleeping take some sleeping
pills
M you're not going to get out of a
really really dark hole if you've had
concussion and you and that's what
you're going to get given and like my
family understood what I was going
through but I didn't have a partner so I
was by myself you know you're really
really isolated when you've got
concussion I was like if I'm going to
get out of this I'm going to go and try
this stuff because it's and I've done
heaps of research and I'd spoken to to a
specialist here outside of New Zealand
Rugby ACC that said you can probably do
the sosyan therapy which is like
mushrooms oh yeah but it's it's not just
take a few Rush
mushrooms there like medical grade stuff
even the MDMA yeah it's medical grade
stuff and then they give you therapy
while you're under the oh influence of
it and we had that that trip to the
states we played a couple development
teams over there for the for the young
boys yeah yeah yeah so it was I was
going to help grow with that team and
I'd had this problem leading up to that
and I was like gray [__] I can't be
involved in this team but I want to come
and I can help when we get over there
but I've got to get my health right M so
basically I was like see at the airport
bro and they trained for you know 6
weeks beforehand and I was struggling
man every day was a
grind and I went and helped out it was
really cool to be a part of that young
group and like some Brad and Stewart and
tan was in that Team all the young boys
that are out there
now um and then after the comp I started
going around the states trying to get
this therapy and um I'd run specialist
and I was talking to a specialist
through NFL over there oh yeah yeah I'd
spent thousands of dollars bro there was
expensive they had a lot more treatment
that was possible like this laser
treatment stuff that you can put in your
nose your ears and
um there's a guy Tim y over in Mur I
think he does things like that in the
the hyperbolic Chambers oxygen that he
can yeah take but ACC doesn't cover that
sort of treatment um and so I couldn't
get into do the emdm emda and the
psilocybon
therapy because they you have to do like
three or four sessions and then stay for
a couple weeks and then do them oh yeah
sort of over a 3 period and it was
expensive in the
states after the trip with the boys I
was living in hotels like just going
from hotel to hotel um but it wasn't
like a
holiday I was still really really worn
out and fatigued and it was like I'd
wake up in the morning go for a wander
around get back home to my hotel and
sleep in the afternoon go back out have
a feed and go back home early that was
my trip yeah and I was trying to get a
break away from NZ did get away from the
the New Zealand Rugby scene and then get
my health right and I was looking for
this therapy well I ended up going down
to Mexico and then taking iosa three
times um and that
was probably one of the hardest things
I've done really ioska is like this root
plant that's a really really strong
hallucinogenic true um trip yeah
and I did that three times
and the experience was wild man what
happens the first
time so you've got a shaman and you can
do it as a group yeah and but I wanted
to do it by myself cuz it's like a
private thing I really need to get this
thing under control cuz i' lost sort of
like my mind wasn't playing game anymore
it was a little bit out of control and I
known that rewiring your mind can it can
be possible with these drugs and the
first time the shaman was around me and
like playing music and they're like they
lead you in and out of this trip and the
drug showed me this this uh like it's
like a story that maybe all of us think
about what is why are we here what's our
purpose what's the meaning of life and
it just I'd crack up
laughing and then I'd try and think and
then something would come to me like a
thought mhm and it'd be trying to tell
me it and then I'd just miss it and I
was like what is that what just happened
I'm trying to understand what happened
and then I'd crack up laughing again and
I try to pick exactly what's coming into
my mind yeah and this went on for about
an hour and a half the same sort of
routine and after the next day I
realized the first trip the experience
that the drug was trying to show me was
just that life was more like
experience and then you take what you
learn from that experience and implement
it into the
next like activity or the next goal in
your life and then you learn again and
you go back to start experience take
your learnings implement it into the
next goal learn again and then go back
to the start and that that seems real
simple
but for me it just gave me like a more
more of a understanding of there's no
real pressure on me this is I guess I
can just go through this slowly I'm
going to learn it's going to be stop
start I'm going to I took a lot of the
pressure off of trying to come right the
second time I took it um I went in there
with an intention of trying to get
something out of it yeah and it wasn't
good just it kicked my ass and I ended
up spewing and you get really bad
diarrhea and what was your intention it
was stuff that I wanted to get sorted
with my family
before I went over there i' had this big
b with my brother-in-law oh yeah and my
sister and we were having like just
normal family stuff and um that was like
I was really hurting from that and I
still haven't spoken to him and maybe
after this I all yeah but he's listening
yeah no maybe
um
but with ay you don't want to go in
there and think you're the boss yeah it
just dominated me that's crazy it um it
made me really really Croc and I was
violently spewing and this went on for 6
or 7even hours and then it takes days to
recover from this thing too
so and I didn't really get deep into the
trip um so I did the first two sessions
over a week period the first one was
really good cuz I felt like it taught me
something about life just the
process and then the second one I tried
to go in there and get something from it
but it didn't work and then the third
one I was like right I'll do it again in
6 weeks I just ate green vegetables no
coffee no alcohol no weed or anything
and I was just chilling in
Mexico and the last time I got it the
guy said hey man you can take like a
couple different portions this is really
really strong or you could just have
this one it's sort of similar to what
you were having and I took the the
strong portion it was maybe three or
four times as much as I'd had the first
two times jeez even though you had that
reaction after the second time yeah yeah
cuz I knew this was bad Jim you walking
around Isel Park thinking that you know
seeing these Visions it was serious for
me man cuz I was at a stage where if I'm
going to come out of this and not do
anything crazy to myself and try and fix
myself this is the way I'm going to do
it yeah so I I I'd done a lot of fasting
and dieting for 6 weeks up to the time I
did it and we went into lockdown in
Mexico oh that's right you're stuck over
there weren't you yeah I was stuck over
there and then
I was in like this 40 40 person um
Airbnb hostel place and everyone left
and the Argentinian dude that was the
manager yeah I got on with him well he
was like bro look after the cats this is
you I'm my
phone and I was in this little Beach
town that no one was there you it was
really chill place and I was like I'm
going hard I'm going to get my [__]
together and take this drug and hope
hope like how it can get my brain rewi
yeah and during that six week period
where I was have you ever spoken to no
this is all new
now during that six week period where I
was dieting hard out um and I was trying
to exercise like I was doing a bit of
Surfing and walking and heaps of yoga I
was doing a hell like a lot of yoga man
and then um but I was also watching
there's this documentary on um Netflix
it's like World War II
in
color and R watched every single episode
over the 6 we period and man I was like
whoa yeah that was really interesting to
see what happened back
then in the' 40s bro that's why I that's
why I post what I'm talking about on on
social media at the moment yeah so I
watched that and I Was preparing to do
this iar and he gave me this really
intense potion and I was like man I'm
taking the whole thing and I'm locking
myself in my room in the DM and no one
was there oh you're by yourself by
myself in this hostel by myself so the
the thing with the the iar is maybe 40
minutes or hour after you first ingest
it you can you sp like you purge so it
comes into your digestive system and
then you spew it back out and then you
go into the
trip well I took it by myself and I'd
had three or four times more than I'd
had previously and then I ended up
falling asleep like I put on the this
YouTube video um of like the the um
Shaman music which was awesome sort of
lead you guide you through the trip and
it was an hour and a half later and I'd
sort of just woken up from asleep and I
heard this massive crack like it was
Thunder and a real loud lightning bolt
and I was like whoa that's out of it
what was that and it was my stomach and
it was hour and a half later I looked at
the time I was like wo this is going to
be narly normally you purge after about
30 40 minutes and it was an hour and a
half yeah and I'd fall into asleep and
then the the crack of the noise was like
[__] it's about to kick in and I sat up
on the edge of the bed like this and I
was a different person what do you mean
a different person I was in osz prison
prisoner so my I was my body was like
just
bone what like skeleton yeah like I had
still I just had no muscle on me oh just
skin imagine a prisoner yeah okay in the
Nazi camps that's you know that tragic
traic time man well that's cuz I'd been
watching all these this documentary and
then my mind had taken me to this space
where I'd become a prisoner and I broke
down crying and I was on the edge of the
bed and I was like [__] this isn't good
and I knew I was still Shan I was still
me my body and my eyes were like showing
me something different
m and then I went into the bathroom
which was just in front of me and I
looked at the mirror and I was like whoa
like the hallucina atic strong bro and I
was I was the same person but my body
had lost all the Flesh in it and I was
just Bor like you imagine some of the
videos you would have seen of that time
and that's what i' been watching and
that's what I became and I just fell on
the ground and start of crying balling
my eyes
out and then spewed up and then for the
next hour and a half tried to deal with
her
mentally fck yeah and I thought um it
was
like people talk about having past life
regressions and experiencing something
that you may have already been and come
to a new life as this but it was just
because I'd put so much time into
learning about what had happened
and but what that taught me was the
appreciation of what I've got yeah yeah
if you see and feel then it wasn't just
the the physical trip it's the emotional
trip that you get with yeah I waska it
changes your whole
Consciousness all right like it was
intense and it was like an appreciation
afterwards that I knew that even though
I'd had concussion and this is how the
drug seems to work like even though I'd
had concussion and I was really
struggling and maybe been a bit suicidal
and lost the those times where I seen
visions and lost a little bit of a track
of my
head if I could get through that we are
fortunate to be here yeah you know like
and I still feel lucky and then it just
after that even though it took me a long
time it took me a couple months to
recover from the trip because it's
actually hard on your mind I really
really changed after that yeah yeah
completely I came back from
overseas took me a couple months to get
my energy back and then I had this new
appreciation of what my life was and
even though I still get concussion
problems I I've just got a way deeper
understanding of how fortunate I am even
though I went through that yeah that's
cool it it was incredibly cool man
and cuz that's all it is it's your
perspective yeah and that's what that
drug taught me is that yeah I've had a
couple H knocks but it's not the end of
it yeah you know you can can grind
through stuff and you can get better and
you can look for different treatment no
matter what happens I'm still lucky than
a lot of people that are bloody
unfortunate at the
moment um so you can't get that sort of
treatment from anything in new Ze you
know and I don't know like the the core
details about how it changes your brain
but they don't have treatments like that
for nothing mhm these these sort of
drugs have been in civilizations for
thousands of years and even doing MDMA
in a therapy M
session that's something that we could
try and investigate for people that have
ongoing concussion problems and the
siloc Cy stuff it's not just the
mushroom under a plant where people trip
out and look at the Stars this stuff can
actually be super helpful because it
just needs to change the way you're
thinking and give you a bit more
strength and perspective like it did for
me what you went through like you
obviously put a huge amount in into
getting right like you've invested a
heap into your mind to get it right and
I guess that's where a lot of guys don't
do it you know they sort of don't give
up but they just don't invest what you
have done into your mind and is that
where it all goes wrong like you you've
obviously done really well to get your
head into the space it is now and um
still have your probably issues but um
you've had made a huge commitment to get
your mind
back on
track what what what drives me I
suppose well doing that drug man yeah
like you think about 3 years I was
really beat up and then after that
season I was probably the most happiest
ever been that still the ring you're
you're on fire that year no that was a
special time and then even after that I
just went bang down and then struggling
and then I knew that was the worst I've
ever been like to have those visions and
consistently was going on every time i'
take this dude for a walk yeah and I
just knew that if if I hadn't if I
didn't do something drastic and I didn't
do it for me I was going to end up
really bad and that's something that I
was pretty fortunate to come across and
I did get the right help and I spoke to
a specialist and she said this is
probably going to be really hard for you
you're probably better to do the
psilocybin one or MDMA but this can work
for people with concussion m you don't
get told that from a lot of places with
maybe around the New Zealand Rugby
format with ACC and stuff yeah it was
like a holistic specialist that I went
and seen and that gave me the confidence
that what I was reading online and
seeing these experience of people that
have done it can change like people that
have bad drug addictions go overseas and
do the I again and it snaps them out of
a really bad heroin addiction like the
worst bro so it can change your mind
these types of drugs and for me it
helped a lot
and it's not that I'm back and it didn't
fix me but it gave me a better
perspective and
then and then after that I went into the
2020 campaign with the um Marcos again
and we managed to win again up at the
blues yeah and I'd I'd thought I'd been
talking to the Landers and then thinking
man if I'm around the boys I'm going to
be right
yeah so I wasn't I knew I was going to
be I would have struggled you know it
was going to be tough during the Lander
season I know they supported me heaps
the coaches brny supported me and like
looked after me heaps as well as they
could and dumo was really
good but being in the environment like
that and trying to get that professional
career going on it was hard on me but it
was be it's better to be in that
environment in a supportive group than
by myself when you you can you know put
yourself in a hole
Yeah so that's really why I got into
that full-time role with the Landers but
I think what gave me the confidence and
the motivation to do it was the waska
trip 100% I wish I wish Billy could do
that man but it cost me money like it
was thousands of dollars I mean it's a
big investment into investment yeah in
that aspect like the financial thing ACC
doesn't pay for those types of things
they'll just think you're a looney bro
yeah yeah
um but I had to do that because
otherwise you know how bad was it going
to be and I think if Billy could have
that support and if I know what I know N
I would have just said bro go do this
I'll come with you and I'll pay for it
yeah because there's nothing that he had
wrong with him that we couldn't have
fixed and yeah why why I did it because
it was that bad JY yeah Isel Park wasn't
a good experience for meing to do
anything yeah and I was it was just it
was simple as that it was I was bad but
it got me here
willing to share enough how why do I
think yeah so I'm comfortable I was
never going to share this and you know I
told
goodie two months ago that that's how
bad I was after that 2019 season it was
only because of Bill passing that I've
seen like man I've got a sayal [__] yeah
cuz I mean I've been trying to get you
on this thing for probably three years
since I started like I I've always loved
your rugby Journey just and just the
rugby Journey itself but what what's
happened post and with all the
concussion and all that adds to it it
gives you so much um opportunity to help
others and um I didn't think I'd ever be
able to get you on but something's
changed like you said in the last few
months and it's awesome to get you on
and be able to share this so openly and
honestly it's it's it's just from the
experience of Bill like yeah shouldn't
have happened and when when Billy passed
I was like oh no this is crazy I was
really shocked the first couple days and
went and seen him up at the hospital and
I was like man this is tragic and I was
gutted but then the next month is when I
realized how it shouldn't have happened
and it made me realize how we're not set
up for these situations yeah we don't
have what it takes to help someone in
that position and we're scared of
helping them because of what it takes
and you have to be honest about what
what some of the [__] people are dealing
with at the moment yeah and I
think um that's what really hurt me and
really
really devastated me was
because if you have a situation like
that with Bill with his stuff that he
was dealing with in life and his ex
partners and his family stuff and his
financial situation wasn't good and he
was here with the girl and working like
how many he inspired so many of the
girls in the FPC team like he used to
hang out with them give them confidence
they seen so many stories since I was
with them this year and how much he he
looked after them and believed in
them this guy that was beat up really
had issues and he was giving still and
then who was there to help him like and
no one's seen it so that made me realize
man if we can't see that in someone if
you have problems you we're not safe
everyone's in a very dangerous position
in mental health and you see this like
around New
Zealand mental Health's never been as
bad as it's ever been at this current
time and um you see Mike
King yeah sacrificing his life for
people in our country you know and
giving so much to try and help the youth
especially and he's up against it
because you see someone like him with
that much human humility sacrificing as
time as effort as fam's life and then
you see our politicians acting like
children using the media to spread false
information they call it misinformation
but really they're just hiding the the
missing information that's quite often
more often than not the truth about
things that are happening our country
and mental Health's one of them 100% and
that's why I think you sharing your
story is going to help so many people
especially anyone who's had concussion
or anyone who's got mental health issues
I think the more people can hear stories
like this the better it's only going to
help but to hear your story to hear what
you've gone through um super inspiring
and super cool to hear how honest you
are about it all and um I know it's
taken a tough situation and losing Billy
to give you the
um I guess confidence to share your
story and knowing that it's going to
help people but I'm so stoked to get you
on the podcast and um have you share it
cheers Jim it's been awesome to be here
and I would say just for Billy's family
like I suppose just incredibly sorry for
the loss so many of us really loved bill
um what he gave to the
union how he was amongst his peers not
just tesman m the three or four super
teams he was that and it's a massive
loss and we're all feeling it so
especially his mom and his sisters
they're amazing people and I'll see them
again so yeah yeah well said cuz like
you said true legend lucky to see him at
the Hurricanes environment at the time
and M all the guys loved him just so
honest very similar to you like would
just say what he thought and um didn't
really worry about what people thought
or appeared that way anyway so it wasn't
scar he wasn't scared of being himself
no and that's what I loved about him he
was himself and he yeah
um yeah was happy to be himself didn't
care what people thought so um so sad
to experience what he went through and M
you were awesome at looking after his
family post that and um you did awesome
work
there cheers J you're a you're a man
yeah